[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I am Pamela Pairo,
PhD, Biological Sciences
from Argentina.
In this presentation, I'm
going to show you how to create
A multilingual website
using blogdown, Hugo, and Netlify.
First of all, why do you
need a personal website?
Having apersonal website is
another way to showcase your CV
or resume with a style and gives
you the freedom to be creative.
By writing posts, you will
practice your communication
skills, you can exchange
knowledge with colleagues,
and therefore, your
network will be expanded.
In my experience, when I
came across with difficulties
or doubts, I had able to solve
the issue, thanks to the posts
shared by others.
And finally, the
personal website
is a platform to
connect with a world.
For those of us who aren't
native English speakers,
it's fundamental to cover
multilingual websites.
In English, to disseminate our
work to the global community,
and in our native language,
to make our website
content more inclusive and
accessible for everyone.
Let's get started.
We began creating a new
report in our GitHub account.
Then in RStudio, create a
new project with contribution
and then load blogdown and Hugo.
You can look at all the
themes and select one
on each Hugo website.
After that, you will
have the default version
of the site in the viewer panel
so it's time to customize.
The main files that are part of
the website are showing here.
In config.toml is
where it is located
global settings for the site.
And in the config/default
folder are the params.toml,
where you can change
the color theme,
the font size of your website,
and add your contact details.
To change what appears in
the navigation menu bar
is necessary to edit
the menus.toml file.
And in language.toml is where
you can change the language
setting.
And how to make your personal
website multilingual?
I'm going to show you an example
of the bilingual website,
English and Spanish.
In the language.toml,
you have to uncomment
the lines for
a second language
to configure your website.
Here, we have the information
about the English part,
for example, the language
code, where it's located
the content, and the title.
Note that the abbreviation of
the languages are predefined.
And so if you want a Portuguese
website, for example,
you need to check which is
the correct abbreviation.
Then each language will need
their own menus.toml file
and a subfolder within
the content folder.
Finally, choose the
default language
that the visitors will see
when they visit your page.
And for make it visible that
the website is multilingual,
check in params.toml that
show language is true.
When you're done with
your edits and you
are happy with your website,
it's time to put it online.
One way to do this
is using netlify.
One of the advantages of
deploying your website
through netlify is that
it allows you
to have a static site
for free and easily.
Basically, it connects to the
remote repository on GitHub
to deploy.
Every change that it
makes on the website
it will be automatically updated
up there to push to GitHub.
It's important that the
Hugo version that you're
running locally must match
with the version that
Netlify is going to
use to build your site.
And how to do that?
Check first your
local version of Hugo
and pick up that netlify.toml
to your project root directory
and specify the Hugo version.
Then go to the Netlify web
page and login with GitHub
to select the report you've
been working with blogdown.
You will see something like
this but with your information.
Go to show advanced and just
in case, write a Hugo version,
and finally, you will
have your website.
In the latest
version of blogdown,
you can set up the Hugo
version by writing this code
and tell to Netlify the Hugo
version with this function.
If you want more
information, here
are some blogs that I used
in this presentation
and you can find me on my
website and on Twitter.
Thank you.